Democratic Party officials have rejected
requests from Fox News to moderate one
of the Democratic presidential debates
Party Chairman Tom Perez is citing a
story in The New Yorker magazine
referencing this channels relationship
with President Trump the story alleges
this channel has become a quote
propaganda vehicle for the president
Perez said in a statement Fox News quote
is not in a position to host a fair and
neutral debate for our candidates here
is a statement from Fox News senior vice
president and managing editor bill
Sammon quote we hope the DNC will
reconsider its decision to bar Chris
Wallace Bret Baier and martha maccallum
all of whom embody the ultimate
journalistic integrity and
professionalism from moderating a
Democratic presidential debate there the
best debate team in the business and
they offer candidates an important
opportunity to make their case to the
largest TV news audience in America
which includes many persuadable voters